this is a production of cornell
university
yeah let's kick off episode six this
year of the cornell turf show
our lawn and landscape show today's
gonna feature a conversation with dr
carl giard of yukon uh we're gonna talk
about a bunch of research projects um
fertilizer related maybe soil testing
related so we'll get to that later
um but as always frank it's our third
week of the spring here uh you always
got a nice little weather wrap up for us
yeah good morning everyone uh for those
joining listening on the podcast or
watching the recording welcome to our
lawn and grounds management edition
uh i'm i'm actually traveling this week
a bit and i'm in a part of the country
where uh i could take a picture of a
person doing this
uh so it's in many parts of the country
where things are getting going a lot of
things are getting applied and i think
as we said in the first week
a lot of times productivity matters a
lot more than optimum timing right you
try to find an optimum time to do things
and you wind up working around it so uh
before we get to carl's tip of the day i
i uh somebody shared this with me
recently
uh a hand unit playing around in the
backyard somewhere in in the uk
um you know people are nuts about grass
and their lungs right and and one of the
things that i've always sort of has been
the guiding principle is that i want to
help this guy i want this guy to be able
to absolutely do this and i actually
think he can do it with other than
mowing not many inputs the biggest
problem he's got is he's got to mow it
all the time because it's pretty low but
other than that in a place like england
where it rains a fair amount where the
soils probably have enough organic
matter in it i don't know what kinds of
pest problems he has but
i want to help a guy like this so carl
why don't you give us uh your stat for
the day
before we get into the conversation
about keeping that stuff sustainable
yeah and we talk about value there frank
the value to that individual homeowner
is is probably aesthetic and there's
probably some mental well-being uh value
going in there for them maintaining
their lawn
but i've been interested in trying to
quantify urban green space value and of
course a lot of that is turf but there's
trees and shrubs and other vegetation
included in that
um and the best numbers we can come up
with in terms of dollars and cents is
really looking at urban green space and
the value that provides to water
retention and reducing storm water
runoff
so there's a couple studies here this
one is from finland basically what they
did is they looked at urban green spaces
they looked at the amount of water that
that penetrates the ground because of
that permeable green space surface
um and they compared that in the cost to
to set up a green space and to manage it
to the cost of what would have been an
impermeable surface maybe a housing
development or parking lots and the cost
of building building water
infrastructure the pipes under the
ground
what they found is urban green spaces
can generate between thirteen hundred
and thirty six hundred dollars
per acre per year of urban green space
so those are some some pretty cool
numbers to have there's those other
studies that have it as high as eight or
ten thousand dollars per acre per year
um you know these areas can can allow
about 70 to 80 percent of the
precipitation that hits that area to
infiltrate back into the groundwater
that's really good it diverts all that
water from the storm water system
so it's really cool to have some values
these are the best ones we have for
water it would be cool to start
quantifying this in terms of noise
pollution maybe air temperature
reduction where it doesn't look like
we're there yet for
for a lot of that stuff with turf grass
but but just a cool little number to
keep in your head when you see maybe
some i know golf courses frequently when
they close in urban areas they get
re-zoned to to impermeable surface
am i good to have some of these numbers
uh when we're looking at situations like
that yeah and and i i would i would
venture to say they're modest uh when
you consider what you'd have to build
right to to compensate for having all
that pervious ground it's unbelievable
carl this is a great stat thanks for
doing that all right let's look at the
weather before we get to our guest um
and just to remind you this time last
week uh
we were talking about how warm it was
the week before and now you can see red
even the deep red basically means normal
which means the the entire region no
surprise was was well below normal and
our our esteemed climatologist rt guy
tano
guy
called it pushing the pause button uh on
the growing season so you can see you
know high elevations as much as 14 below
normal but certainly along the coast a
little warmer inline a little cooler uh
precip again
generally adequate
most people got between a quarter and a
half an inch a couple in northern
reaches got even more uh the connecticut
river valley and even long island look
like they got about an inch or two so so
pretty pretty moist uh not not lacking
for moisture and looking forward the six
to ten outlook day 10 outlook is calling
for mostly normal but near normal but
above normal along the coast so if we
look at our forecast website from a
growing degree day perspective
you know how the uh entire growing
season will progress regarding heat
units and how it's all advancing
biologically is going to be governed by
growing degree days at least that's the
way we're not governed but somewhat
easily tracked using growing degree days
and you can see we're still not
accumulating very many uh throughout the
region so you know we're looking at 50
you know 40 to 50 degree temperatures
lows in the 40s at night highs in the
upper 50s so 40 to 60 degrees looking
forward a rainfall looks like we're
going to be wet again uh the prediction
for this uh the next six to ten days and
if you just look at the next three days
um
uh
our forecast for the next three days you
can see actually a nice swath going
through the hudson valley and with the
pioneer valley
almost as a little over an inch maybe
even as much as two inches
in that swath in areas where i'm not
sure they actually need the rainfall now
to the south when you get down south
jersey philly they're on the dry side so
some of that moisture could be very
welcome in those regions
all right let's keep going here now the
soil temperature just the other day
again if you recall last week we were as
much as 52 and now we're uh lucky to be
reaching into the 40s uh
upper 40s and now that doesn't look like
it's going to be changing dramatically
so again that pause button is uh clearly
what's going on now the interesting
thing and i talked about this yesterday
in the golf session uh matt elmore
tweeted out that the japanese still
grass is emerging now you may not even
know japanese still grass unless you're
working in a landscape with a lot of
shaded areas particularly around the new
york metropolitan areas where we're
seeing it uh expand dramatically
it's a very highly invasive plant it's a
c4 plant so it's actually a warm season
grass that has really high shade
tolerance and one of the things that
we're seeing as it starts to come out
into shaded lawns
is because it comes out so early it
completely evades a lot of our
pre-emergent uh crabgrass materials now
as we get on during the season i'm going
to talk about maybe kailinga and maybe
goose grass that are also successfully
alluding uh or missing uh uh you know
getting away from
our pre-emergent crabgrass stuff so uh i
think it's something moving forward
we're gonna talk more about
the spring continues to progress for
those of you that pay attention to the
national phenology network while we all
hit the pause button we still are fairly
ahead of normal when you look at leaf
index from just the other day how it's
progressing along the coast and moving
up uh into the interior of the northeast
now i talked a little bit about it
yesterday i want to expand a little bit
about this today before we get to our
nutrient conversation this concept of
false springs right this is very uh this
has a lot of implications of course i
don't have to explain this very much to
fruit growers uh east of the mississippi
because they experienced this issue a
number of years ago when you look here
at this chart uh that was uh was a it
was a position paper written about why
we needed more research on this kind of
information you're looking at what
they're calling false springs the
30-year average and a typical spring
right so a typical spring you see this
dark blue line here here's the gray line
it's a normal spring where uh our
30-year average where temperatures stay
well below normal and plants remain
dormant they start emerging well after
the risk of serious frost or
cold temperatures is going to occur
this idea of fall springs is this
extended warming period now that we're
starting to see where plants break
dormancy and then make them more
vulnerable to frost now of course the
golf industry is dealing with a lot of
this now from potentially with the
winter damage that it's experiencing but
i actually talked about it yesterday
i'll refer you to it again today there's
some really cool fall spring research
going on at the university of minnesota
looking at uh tall fescue turf type tall
fescues that are a little bit uh cold
sensitive uh when you put them out in
the plains cold states like minnesota so
florence sessoms is leading a project in
eric watkins program out at the
university of minnesota where they're
building these tents uh over these areas
and also doing similar work in the
greenhouse and growth chambers and on
the left you see a plant you know the
plants over here coming out of dormancy
very successfully no damage here is one
day of warm-up and then followed by cold
temperatures and here's five days of
warm warm-up uh followed by uh
five days of fall spring followed by
cold temperatures and you can see tall
fescues uh are going to have some
particular problems with that and and i
think golf's got you know annual
bluegrass that's one of those issues and
i think
a lot of our recommendations for turf
type tall fescue
i think still work for us because our
winters are still pretty warm but in
minnesota uh in places like that we're
definitely seeing even lawn grasses
impacted by that warm-up um and then uh
just a reminder about seeding at this
time of year
a colleague
at purdue university many years ago did
a study looking at
timing of seeding and of course no
surprise kentucky bluegrass tall fescue
and perennial ryegrass right across the
board successfully look good
uh
when they're seated in september right
the following uh july right the
following year right because that's
ideal timing you get a little later and
you see perennial rye does good you get
into november uh in indiana you still
got good conditions you can get good
tall fescue but the focus here is spring
growth so there actually appears to be
some benefit particularly if you want to
increase your kentucky bluegrass
populations in the spring is to start
seeding those plants now looks like tall
fescue and ryegrass
do pretty good with early seedings as
well all right carl now we're going to
start the conversation about this
wonderful publication that i know you
were involved in i think marty was
involved in it years ago
looking at
looking at a fertilization of turf and i
look at this a lot at lawns particularly
from a water quality lens right how do
we make sure
we're maintaining regional water quality
uh and it's very simple i don't want to
spend a lot of time on it right rate all
the basic things we know you did a
wonderful job i commend people carl
let's put the link in i've talked about
this in the past on the show um and for
those of you listening you know you can
go check uh the recording or we can find
a way to get you to links for sure uh on
the website but for sure you know
non-sensitive areas of trying to lay out
a program and more sensitive areas in
very simple terms you know this is maybe
not ideal
now
the next evolution i think beyond sort
of nitrogen management and the things
that came up in that publication are you
know the whole idea in the spring that
we soil test and we not got to get that
fertilizer down
to meet those minimum expectations
and now you're refining this
uh for the university of you know for
for new england soils right so you've
got this project underway and i'm going
to give you a chance to talk about it
but
what i want to talk about is the cooler
paper i saw your grad student present
this at the crop science meetings i
think it was this it might have been an
evolution of this correct me if i'm
wrong but in this case i want to focus
on
how we can use mlsn for everything but
really you can't use it necessarily for
nitrogen
so one of the things that underlies the
challenge with testing for nitrogen
is that you know you don't know how it's
going to release we it's more it's it's
it's transient will a snapshot tell you
anything and some of the basis for this
thinking goes back to the 70s that you
know soils build organic matter this is
actually lawn soils on long island the
very famous water resource institute
paper that been cited you know a million
times by people that shows how the
nitrogen concentration
in organic matter uh continues to
increase now carl here's where i'm going
with this brother and i know you're
lined up with this because you've done
this work but when you look at kevin
frank's uh the michigan state monolith
lysimeter work
right early on um you know they applied
fertilizers and you can see here uh did
not get any leaching uh in the early
days now this is year six
so in years one through six
all of these leachates from these two
fertilizer strategies this is two pounds
and this is five pounds right there's
two fertilizer strategies here it took
many years for it to build up before it
the high rate began to become very leaky
and when you look at it over a really
long period of time
after that
pulse six years in they lowered the
nitrogen the larger nitrogen rate
down to three and a half four pounds and
you're starting to see uh those numbers
come way down i haven't looked at this
data since but it can't just be
that the fertilizer rate you're applying
is leading to this now we then use some
of this stuff carl to write a few years
ago when some legislation was coming
through on defensible nitrogen rates
right how much could you put on
reasonably
be what does research say you could put
on reasonably
before it like leak you know leaked out
in a study like this like long term and
short term so
depending on what you use the turf for
it could be as little as one to two
could be as much as four to six but
ultimately we came down in the you know
looks like two to two point seven you
want about point five to point seven no
more than that in a single lap depending
on the soil
but it it pales in comparison to what
you're trying to do
with this particular line of inquiry
trying to predict with some tools
so it'll help people use different tools
um this idea of
uh developing a slant a sufficiency
level for nitrogen and i'll cut right to
the chase carl and then i'll give you
the chance to chime in here now because
this i'm sure a lot to unpack here
brother but ultimately what i gathered
from your work
was basically asking is there a way to
that we can test and then have some
probability like okay if it's this and i
add fertilizer it is is it going to be
any more than
x
so to me this is honing in on it uh it
might have problems right it's only
testing maybe on one soil even though
you've got two species over a nine year
period so i mean it's a good body of
data that did this work but i'll leave
the graph up here for a second and and
invite you welcome to the show carl i
hope i'm not taking too much time now
but how am i how are we doing on time
how are we doing on time
all right so i'm going to shut up now
carl what do you want to start with
where do i ask the question what how did
this work turn out what do you think
all right so uh the basis of what was
really driving this work
is that what is the correct rate of
nitrogen
we tend to use a
arbitrary rate because it's like well
the best science may say
this but we'll cut it down a little bit
we'll look at some leaching data we'll
do this
but the problem with that is is that
every site is different but we're using
a generalized rate across a huge
geographical area at a specific and i
call it an arbitrary rate now is that
rate right for you it may be it may be
on your your instance on there but we
are really guessing we are really
guessing and some people guess very good
um
a lot of long-term turf managers are
still successful in the business they
pretty much have an intuitive sense of
looking at their turf and saying uh it
looks a little hungry might need a
little bit uh
on there but we really still don't know
and as the graph he showed from the um
long island study on there we are we do
have mineralization potentials so our
thinking here and this was more of a
proof of concept can we use a particular
uh
relatively easy commercial commercially
available
uh test to give us an indication of what
our mineralization potential may be and
then backward from that
once we do know can we classify our turf
areas as to their particular response
what they may have to a nitrogen
response now i will guarantee that every
turf manager that is in here listening
has some areas where
they have put nitrogen down and may have
seen a response or maybe put nitrogen
down and may not have seen as big a
response as maybe they were anticipating
we all have that we all have those turf
areas in there but we tend to stay
with a a a single uh common rate
particularly if you're in the business
of doing that you know time is money and
you calibrate your spreaders for doing
basically the same way you get out there
you put it on there it's a it's a
business model type of a thing so we're
trying to look at is there any way to
help with that now
also every turf manager
actually manages by probability what's
the first thing most turf managers do
every day what's the very first thing
they open up their their app on their
phone and look at the weather what's the
probability that it's going to rain that
drives so much or what's the probability
of a certain temperature that drives so
much of turf management so
what we were trying to do is since most
turf managers already do this
either as practice or instinctively
looking at probability let's put this
into a nutrient management aspect on
there but they really haven't had any
tools other than visual cues at this
point to guide that
so we looked at these
solvida tests that are commercially
available i have absolutely no financial
interest in this i know that april says
it it's funny when you publish a paper
nowadays carl they make you disclose all
this stuff right if you read down the
disclaimers so that's good let's say it
that way people know it we're not
pushing any particular test it just
happened to be a tool and again since i
may not ever get you like this again
you've been at this for a while carl
i've been trying to get you know you
tried the those little drip uh sap tests
then you did the dgci the spectral
imaging testing i mean i've known you i
paid attention to you for a long time
and you've been at this i guess before
you go into this a little bit more
is this what you're thinking you're
leaning towards is this the natural
evolution for the work do you think this
is the place we're going to find a way
to take the arbitrariness out of it
i well it will it will certainly help i
think right now i think i'm confident
that
at the least with these tests we you
should be able to use these to at least
categorize your soils
so
and we we present in the papers and
anytime we present this information we
give a generalized type of fertilizer
adjustment
so really if if you would say use these
tests in your turf area and some of this
for some turf managers may already
intuitively kind of suspect it's like i
put a lot of nitrogen down here on there
but i really don't see that greater
response and i've even cut down and it
still looks about the same so that means
you've got a lot of
natural mineralization or available
nitrogen going on you don't have to put
as much nitrogen going down
so we're pretty confident that these
tests will at the minimum allow you to
designate your areas that you are
managing as to their probability of
response if the values come out very low
on the test
you may need to put on what your current
rate or what your maximum rate or your
optimum rate let's say and if it's at a
a little higher level well maybe you can
cut down maybe to three quarters of what
you put down and if it's a little higher
on the values maybe cut down to half or
a third and then if it's high high
values maybe cut down to a quarter or
maybe nothing and just see what happens
all right so let me ask you a couple let
me ask you a couple of questions now
first give us a little primer in simple
terms on an elevator speech what is a
solvida test actually measuring i
associate it with compost testing
right i associate it historically as a
compost test you're telling me i can use
it potentially as a diagnostic tool for
soil and just a little snippet and what
a solvida test actually is measuring
excellent point and i should have
mentioned that it was indeed originally
developed as a compost uh test to say
whether or not you've hit that heat rise
and you've got a cured compost however
when that information came out a lot of
the soil scientists immediately saw the
value of maybe looking at organic matter
uh decomposition soil
respiration and so they do have a test
developed
for
soils
and this is the woods end laboratory up
in maine and
they have developed one specifically for
soils now the it is
is abbreviated as the s-l-a-n
and unfortunately i think that's a
unfortunate abbreviation because we
already have a slan for sufficiency
level of available nutrients for
something else what is theirs
yes this is so their slant stands for
the soil labile amino nitrogen test
it's it's actually measuring a very very
active or reactive or highly uh
mineralizable form a a a labile amino
nitrogen and labile just means it's it
breaks down very very quickly it's an
active form
and so most of that uh amino nitrogen is
actually tied up in the bacterial cell
walls yeah and so
and particularly if turf if you look at
the literature uh under grassland
situations the microbial biome
population is dominated by bacteria
okay let me ask okay so this is the
interesting point now i'm gonna get in
the weeds but it has a big practical
implication and it's one thing to do
this solvita test and tell me the
probability that adding a fertilizer
might work
but what i've realized from particularly
now that you've introduced a microbial
aspect to it
how do you relate this to how a soil or
a fertilizer will respond when the soils
are cooler and not able to process that
mineralizable and as effectively versus
the heat of the summer when they're warm
and when it rains you see how your soils
function right because temperature isn't
limiting them it rains in the spring you
don't get a surge it rains in the summer
you get a surge how can i feel you know
as i'm thinking through a spring
nitrogen application
is this a good tool for that or i have
to wait maybe till that microbial system
gets going to be able to use this tool
no oh god frank these are all excellent
questions these are really really good
because
uh
this this data was actually based on a
single early spring test
so we figured that the way we were
developing this test is that
let's not have any other additional task
that most turf managers most i we assume
most will either do in the spring or the
fall
now
what we don't have on this particular
study but we do have on the one we're
finishing up now is that how does this
change across the season right so that's
the question you're really getting at
what when's the best time to do this
well it turns out if you are not putting
on a large amount of organic matter
additions each year
now maybe some of the organic folks will
be doing this but generally in the most
part this does not change that much
over the season so the data we have now
and it's not presented in in what we're
showing now but i'll tell you we're
working on that data now is that uh and
there's another solvida test too called
the carbon dioxide burst test so they're
very similar and and the co2 burst test
is more of microbial activity
and but they're they're correlated very
very well so either one and we find that
with the the soviet slan test
uh taking that anywhere up through
uh most of the growing season uh do that
we do find it dropping down as you get
into late october november so it does
drop down a little bit uh and that but
that may be
due to plant uptake of what is available
in the amino nitrogen okay so yeah again
this may be my last two minutes getting
asked these good questions i'm gonna
take advantage one more time uh before
our former colleague who has
moved into retirement many years ago
marty petrovic uh marty and i used to
talk about this endlessly right because
of the long island stuff and it's like
he always felt the same way you did
these are i can't marty always he was
the sort of guy used to get called to
court all the time for like as an expert
witness and he goes frank i'm not
putting my hand up on a stand and
testifying to any nitrogen rate that's
what he used to tell me
but he did used to say this he goes my
sense is once these lawns mature to a
certain age 25 35 years that essentially
every time they get a certain amount of
water they're gonna release nitrogen
right they're gonna and in fact you
could look at fertilization between
certain soil temperatures by just how
you water if you if it's dry and you
throw some water
you'll get that system functioning
do do you really think that that's
probably something we could think more
about that one way to think of it in
simple terms is if you want to cut back
applying fertilizer when your soil
soil's warm which might be when this
pool contributes the most uh you could
do it by maybe if you had an irrigation
system just sling in some water sure
well the other thing too with a lot of
particularly in high cut lawns a lot of
this clippings are being returned
and so and so that needs so all of that
needs to up until this point we really
don't necessarily account for that uh we
know you know if we want to be
intellectually honest with ourselves we
know that this is all contributing we
get atmospheric deposition maybe a
little bit the irrigation we all that
but it's never never accounted for
because we haven't had the tools i don't
think or easily readily available
now i think we do now we think we do and
i think
this has um something to uh that will
will help with that um
it's like anything else it's going to be
a change to the current system and what
i have found over the 20 plus years that
when i got into turf working on nitrogen
i thought oh good this will be easier i
go come over from forage grasses into
turf nitrogen i'll i'll knock this out
of the park in about a year or two and
so 25 years later i'm still you know
trying to figure out what's what's going
on uh
so i i it's it's going to be changing
changing human behavior in practices
um
it's got to have a a political will from
the standpoint of not
not being to a any political
organization no i mean a political will
of making a a decision based on a
business model decision and i've
advocated for these tests to be uh if
you're in lawn care company or something
introduce these tests as part of your
your your monitoring program charge well
all all i can tell you is and carl will
appreciate this and maybe we'll take a
question carl uh carl c carl we'll take
a question or two if there's any but but
i will say that um
partly what's always fascinated me is
i've always felt like you've tried to
get us more quantitative ability to do
these things that i thought was
arbitrary as well and i i look at a carl
c as a as a as an eagle in our bmps
right if you're a lawn care provider and
you want to do best management practices
for water quality protection and you
really want to dial in your nutrient
program instead of just offering a long
an organic service which seems to do
people into thinking it's sustainable uh
why don't you say let me dial in your
rate by seeing what your soil is going
to do uh i i think there's a lot of hope
for that carl what about a question we
got any questions from the group
yes so one of the questions is actually
from ben palmer asking about
how much n is returned when you're
returning clippings per year and i i've
seen about a pound depending um
it depends on how much growth
it is too but i think the bigger
question is
and one of the topics the themes i'm
noticing from your guys's conversation
is we've all always known these general
principles if your soil has high organic
matter
um it's going to have more mineralizable
and if it's a sandy soil it's going to
leach quicker if it's
um
if you're applying more fertilizer if
you're returning clippings all these
things we know
in our head kind of how they change our
fertilizer but what i'm hearing you guys
talk about is
we're moving closer to like a model a
model of growth that we can input okay
i've got
x turf species y soil and my solvida co2
burst test says this here's the
probability of a fertilizer um
changing my growth rate does that sound
right and carl with a k do you think
that's that's on the horizon for us
well sure
look how much we're doing now with our
mobile devices
and just it's used so many app doing
everything and and they're even i didn't
even mention it but frank frank knows
that i've done work with uh turf
reflectance and media then you can get
that on your phone now or your ipad you
can get programs to do that
and i don't see why not there cannot be
something where you go out with your
phone snap a few pictures and then with
certain apps input your soil information
some of the weather data on there and
at least come out with a problem
mechanistic model to give you a
probability of whether or not
you need to apply or should apply maybe
that's going to be putting in and
including um
some of the solvida tests or whatever
other information that you have
yes
we're doing that now for everything else
what why is turf like this this magical
untouchable magical beast that you know
a pound of end per thousand square feet
per year at every application it's so
great three or four times a year you're
looking back at the bridge you built for
25 years and you're just throwing
gasoline and throwing a match on yeah
i'm bombarded
now the other thing if you
pop up uh frank uh uh kevin frank's data
yeah
look when most of the leaching occurs in
northern climates it's in the fall and
early winter what do we do right before
then well we've got our paradigm of fall
fertilization
why in god's name are we putting down
fertilizer nitrogen at a time when you
know that most of it and look it and
i'll you know if you don't believe my
data look at the data that cornell has
done and what doug soldat has done and
doing that and every time anybody now is
dialing in looking at fall fertilization
it's like
maybe we better rethink this
because
yeah i think there's been a shift in
that i really i really do and listen
carl
only because it might be the last time
we get the chat like this we went over
the fastest 30 minutes into 36 minutes
carl gillard so great to see you if we
if i don't get to chat with you again i
hope you have a wonderful retirement and
i'll just tell you
you have made an enormous contribution
to a discipline that you thought you
were going to fix in a year
i would glad you hung around for 25
years because it really has made i think
for those of us paying attention to want
to be better at it i think you've really
contributed a fair amount thanks carl
thanks for getting i appreciate it
thanks thanks bye all right thanks
everybody get us out of here yeah we've
uh it's we'll still call it the fastest
30 minutes it probably felt like that uh
you know we're getting carl and frank
all worked up about nitrogen and
fertilizer so
thanks everybody for joining us today
we'll be back again next week on
thursday for a golf show take care bye
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu